but first tonight kanye west as you know
spoke at the white house yesterday he
drew a huge amount of news coverage for
what he said
commentators generally were not
impressed many of them dismissed the
whole thing as a
sideshow and in some ways they were
right about that
west made a number of interesting points
but in the end he's just an entertainer
donald trump was there too he is the
president of the united states he's the
most powerful man
in the world and yet also like the rest
of us ultimately he's just
passing through there will be other
presidents the question
we should care about is bigger than two
people any two people
this is the most important question is
america still a free country
can people openly express their beliefs
in public are they still
allowed to say what they think is true
without being punished for it
that's what matters most it matters far
more than any single politician
or rapper or midterm election and by
that standard the one that matters
what happened yesterday at the white
house tells us a lot about america right
now
much of it ominous in case you missed it
here's part of what kanye west said
yesterday
you know people expect that if you're
black you have to be democrat
i have a i have conversations that
basically
said that welfare is the reason why a
lot of black people end up being a
democrat they say
you know first of all it's it's a limit
to amount of jobs
uh so the fathers lose the jobs and they
say
we'll give you more money for having
more kids in your home
so to sum up kanye west says that
liberal social programs have undermined
the black family he notes that african
americans face
enormous pressure not to support
republicans and he suggests that the
democratic party often displays
undisguised contempt for men and for
masculinity
when you think about it these are not
especially controversial statements
they are all obviously true for one
thing anyone who pays any attention at
all
already knows that what wes said is
so hard to rebut factually that nobody
even tried to do that
instead they attacked him as a person
they attacked his decency
and his mental condition now if that
sounds familiar it's because this is now
a universal tactic
on the left they don't want to argue
with you they want to denounce you
watch don lemon over at cnn deliver his
deep critique of president trump's
domestic program
why doesn't president trump condemn
racism his own words and actions tell
you why
he's a racist but let me not mince words
here
this president trafficks in racism
roseanne's tweet was
straight up racist yet the president
failed to condemn it
why because he can't because his own
words and actions are
racist too and we have to stop
pretending that this president
has nothing to do with it that he's not
emboldening
racist and racism the best thing about
this style of argument is you don't
actually have to
learn anything master any details
because
facts are irrelevant what you're saying
is my opponents are bad
people you must ignore them
so it wasn't obvious though how the left
was going to pull any of this off with
kanye west at first they attacked him as
crazy but that didn't really make sense
if you think that kanye west is mentally
ill
why are you attacking him for that and
of course you can't really call kanye
west
racist because he's black but then don
lemon cracked the code
you must ignore kanye west lemon
explains to the rest of us
because kanye west is a traitor to his
race
watch this what i saw was a minstrel
show today
him in front of all of these white
people mostly white people
embarrassing himself and embarrassing
americans but mostly african-americans
and now all of a sudden
he is the person who represents the
african-american community
he doesn't this was an embarrassment
kanye's mother is rolling over in her
grave
there you go according to don lemon
kanye west's skin color means that he is
required to behave
in a very specific way if he chooses to
behave in any other way
he should be punished because according
to don lemon kanye west's race
is his destiny it defines everything
about him
people used to talk like this 50 years
ago as they defended racial segregation
in the american south
what a surprise to learn they are still
talking that way
but this time it's on cnn michael eric
dyson went even further though than don
lemon
for the crime of being friendly with a
politician he doesn't like
he says that kanye west is actually
despite all obvious appearances
a practicing white supremacist watch
this
this is time for us to say kanye we as
african-american people
cannot stand idly by while you give
cover
to a man who has proved to be a white
supremacist this is white supremacy by
ventriloquism
a black mouth is moving but right racist
ideals are
are flowing from kanye west's mouth
keep in mind they're calling kanye west
the crazy one
but of course they don't mean it they
wouldn't be so angry at him if they did
mean it
the real fear is that kanye west isn't
crazy at
all and that you might listen to him
this isn't about kanye west or even
about donald trump
it's about power most things are
suddenly a small number of ideological
gatekeepers basically control what
everybody
else in this country is allowed to say
and think
these people work at google and cnn in
the u.s senate maybe even down the hall
from your office
in the corporate sensitivity department
they're enjoying the power they have
because people always
enjoy having power but they're worried
because they can know they can only
maintain this system the one they
benefit from
through fear and lying if enough people
to decide to ignore their rules and
think for themselves
it's over they have no more power a
whole country of people saying what they
think is true
that's their nightmare that's what they
fear the most it could all start by the
way with a single person i don't know
a rapper speaking stream of
consciousness one afternoon in the oval
office
and from there who knows where it could
go other people might stop hiding their
unapproved opinions
it's a terrifying prospect to them free
speech is like a
virus better to stop it while you can
don lemon is no genius but he
understands that dory murdoch is a
contributing editor at national review
online and he joins us tonight
dory what are they saying really are
they saying
about kanye west well tucker they're
saying a couple of things one is that
unlike back in the 1960s during the
civil rights movement you may recall
a number of protesters holding up signs
that said i am a man
yeah essentially they're saying that
he's not able to say that he has to hold
up sign says i'm not a man
i'm not allowed to think on my own i may
not have my own opinions i must do
whatever the liberal orthodoxy says
and because he didn't do that people
aren't saying well kanye was wrong on
this or he's mistaken
that issue he had his facts wrong they
denounced him as a minstrel
uh negro kind of words you've not heard
since uh since jim crow was uh was
buried back uh
back in the mid 1960s i think that's
extraordinary you know you come on every
night people disagree with you and
tell you you're wrong but nobody says
well tucker you're a bad white person
or you're white trash or anything
exactly right they just disagree with
your views but they attack him as a
human being
and and try to remove his his blackness
from him which i think is extraordinary
and hideous and disgusting but they're
not even really treating him as a human
being with autonomy and the right to
form his own opinions reach his own
conclusions they're treating him as an
interchangeable
piece of a larger hole like a nameless
faceless drone who must obey
he's a drone who's fallen out of line
and they can't have that and the fear i
think they have is that people will
listen to him and start
asking questions like well isn't it
interesting that we've had a president
who after
a year and a half has managed to bring
black unemployment to its lowest level
in history we're growing it twice where
we were two years ago
and suddenly black folks start to think
well maybe this president's working out
his policies aren't
aren't this racist attack we've heard
about that they might suddenly start
voting that way and the democrats will
be in very big trouble so
very important to knock kanye down
attack and degrade him
and dehumanize him which is exactly what
the left is doing tonight have you ever
seen anything like this so i mean did am
i misremembering we're roughly the same
age i don't remember
people using terms like terms that are
so ugly i'm actually not going to repeat
them but i'm not a very shy person
people didn't used to talk like that in
television did they until recently
uh not so much not to this level and
almost as uniformly and and
and consistently across uh any number of
cable channels
uh various people coming out uh this uh
professor uh
dyson from my alma mater george shetty
university uh
saying the kinds the kinds of things he
is that uh kanye is a white supremacist
that
he's a ventriloquist that uh i guess
trump is the puppeteer you know pulling
his strings or something like this
i mean if donald trump were a white
supremacist why would he have
one of america's biggest rappers in the
oval office wouldn't that
destroy his white supremacist base i
mean if david duke were president do you
think he'd have
kanye west in the oval office this makes
absolutely absolutely no sense it's not
logical
and i think it just shows the tremendous
state of desperation
in which the democratic left finds
itself today it's
it's interesting the level of bullying
that goes on i mean you think if they
really thought he was crazy
and they're saying he's crazy because i
guess it's okay to mock people's mental
illness down that's right that's it
that's a new rule too
same isn't it exactly but if they really
thought that he was out of his mind they
would smile indulgently like you do to
the guy eating imaginary insects on the
bus
right exactly he's crazy or you call a
doctor and help mount somebody exactly
right
thank you exactly he talked about job
creation he talked about specifically
improving the economy
and the crime disaster in chicago he
talked about montessori schools i mean
it was definitely a stream of
consciousness
kind of a monologue if you will but he
had some very solid things he had to say
in there
he also made the point that why is it
where is it written that if you're black
you have to be a democrat and he seems
to be breaking away from that notion
and if enough blacks break away from
that notion the democrats are going to
be in really bad shape because
blacks constitute such a large part of
the democratic base that if
8 out of 10 black folks stay democrat
and 2 out of 10
decide to vote republican the democrats
are going to go the way of the whig
party and they'll be gone
so but wouldn't look you've got you've
been in journalism a long time you've
got opinions i certainly have them
they're on full display
but wouldn't you feel a little bit
wouldn't your conscience ache a little
if you found yourself night after night
repeating the nastiest possible talking
points on behalf of a political party
and pretending that you were a
journalist
would you do that i've heard you attack
the republican party i wouldn't do that
i try to talk about i present my
opinions and try to back them up with
facts and figures
and uh and quotes and and evidence uh
these people aren't doing that they
scream oh trump's a racist he's a racist
he's a racist
where's the proof of that if he were
racist why did he go campaign in uh
black churches in detroit and in flint
michigan why did he go campaign
in a charter school in cleveland why did
he bring in one of his very first acts
the presidents of historically black
colleges and universities and
welcomed them and then opened a white an
office in the white house to assist them
he made the mlk birthplace a national
historical monument something obama
could have done
he had eight years he couldn't be
bothered couldn't bother to do that
and uh president trump actually did that
again not the kind of behavior
you'd expect to see out of a white
supremacist they're just saying what
they think they have to say it's just
remarkable what hacks they are it's
really contemptible and cruel i mean
yeah and cruel i totally agree i've
never look i don't know anything about
kanye west i you know i'm not having
dinner with him but it's just it's mean
and i don't it's too much
even for me and i'm a talk show host
very mean for the
party of tolerance i'd say yeah i agree
with that great to see you tonight thank
you thank you